you know then that throughout the
history of psychology there's been a
struggle between what can we learn about
psychological states in humans and
animals what can we learn about
psychological states by studying
conscious states and people and
unconscious states and so forth there's
always the struggle between animal human
conscious unconscious and the
behaviorist got rid of that because they
said it's you know we can't study
consciousness because it's not an
objective thing that you can measure so
they said what we should do is just
study observable behavior so they got
rid of consciousness then the cognitive
revolution came along and brought the
mind back to psychology but it didn't
bring back the mind that the behaviorist
got rid of it brought back the mind is
an information processing device so when
I got interested in emotion in the 70s
emotion was still being thought of in
terms of subjective conscious
experiences whereas other aspects of
psychology like perception and memory
were thought of as information
processing functions so you could learn
a lot about the way the brain processes
the redness of a sunset without actually
knowing how it experiences the redness
of the sunset but in the study of
emotion that kind of bleep it not